happy friday today we're going to talk
about far cry 6's free dlc plan which
includes a mission with danny trejo plus
we're going to dive into the new
challenger in the video game height wars
and tell you when you can play the call
of duty vanguard beta my name is devonte
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news
let's kick this off with some far cry
talk because ubisoft confirmed more
details about its post-launch plans the
roadmap includes crossover missions
featuring rambo stranger things and the
actor danny trejo each mission is part
of the free updates coming to far cry 6
at some point after launch and will be
playable solo or in co-op with two
players the dlc will also feature weekly
insurgency missions and events called
special operations as implied the
insurgencies take place each week and
involve players tracking down anton
castillo's underlings to earn new gear
the special operations takes players to
unique new areas of far cry's fictional
country yara and introduce new gameplay
mechanics as players snatch highly
unstable chemical weapons from anton's
arms dealers and get to the extraction
point before it overheats as for the
crossover missions the danny trejo
mission involves helping trejo sell his
tacos by murdering a lot of people in
the dany and danny versus everybody dlc
the rambo all the blood dlc sees a rambo
super fan teaming up with rambo himself
and what is described as a blood soaked
rampage straight out of an 80s action
blockbuster and in the far cry 6
stranger things dlc the vanishing
something happens to your cute little
dog chorizo and you must find and save
him and just in case you missed it when
i said it earlier
all of those are free to owners of far
cry 6 and separate from the 40 season
pass that will include missions where
you get to play as the villains from
previous far cry games my levels of
excitement for this game just keep on
getting higher as october gets closer
but alright if you haven't noticed there
has been a running question in gaming
this year as thirsty fans continue to
wonder just how tall certain video game
characters are following yesterday's
playstation showcase god of war
ragnaroks as guardian deity tyr has
become the newest giant for fans to
drool over and although he's big he's
not quite lady dematrice big
playstation's uk twitter account asked
god of war ragnarok developer sony santa
monica for some numbers on the
imprisoned deities height and the studio
obliged by revealing that he stands at
an imposing eight feet and five inches
on the fictional scale tyr is an entire
foot shorter than lady demetris and is
dwarfed by gaming's current tall lady
record holder destiny 2's witch queen
even if tears stood on the shoulders of
kratos who's pretty tall himself he
would still have to look up at the witch
queen but okay be honest with me are you
prone to fomo when it comes to gaming
are you sitting there right now thinking
but devonte how do i get into that call
of duty vanguard beta early this weekend
well let me explain to get into the
first weekend of the call of duty
vanguard beta you must have purchased
the game on a playstation system if it
was pre-ordered via psn that's an
automatic process while physical
pre-orders will require entering a code
but for those of you who are not on
playstation or those who just don't want
to pre-order like me you can play on the
following dates september 16th starts
early access for xbox and pc as well as
playstation opening up to everyone then
on september 18th to the 20th the beta
will be open to everyone on all
platforms no pre-order required
hit the comment section and let me know
what you're getting into this weekend
gaming or otherwise and by the time
you're watching this i've probably
already done a live stream of the new
world open beta from amazon games so go
over and check out that vod to see me uh
probably struggle a little bit you know
it's been a while since i played an mmo
[Music]